Brooklyn nine-nine yeah was very
exciting you had some drama here yeah
drama you were cancelled by Fox okay
uh-huh
then everyone gets upset you're picked
up by NBC yeah so now you're you're but
then you're you're going back to NBC
right yeah yeah I started off on NBC
yeah SNL right alums yeah I was there a
long time before you yeah consider us
contemporaries we're really not had at
all I looked up to you and I still do I
was so I was there back in the 50s yeah
people who know sign out live started
way back in the 50s and it was in black
and white and it was a lot of fun yeah
but then you sketch they should write
that sketch
only if we get paid not we so you go
back to NBC go back to NBC it's
interesting obviously we're thrilled
NBC though when we first took Brooklyn
99 out passed on it oh and I was coming
off SNL and I felt very close with
everyone at NBC and I took it very
personally and I kind of told everyone
there to go to hell and then you know I
kind of like rolled down to the NBC
building kind of like just swipe stuff
off people's desks and you weren't you
didn't take it nicely you didn't I was
pretty ticked I went down in the
mailroom and pumped some people yeah
kicked the peacock yeah I kicked that
peacock yeah
so suffice it to say the last month or
so has been a bit of an apology tour
[Laughter]
but we're very happy to be back and just
on it all you know what's so nice is you
stay at fox announces they're not
picking up your show and that happens to
a lot of shows it happened to your show
people went nuts a lot of fans came out
in support yes and they were tweeting
these very nice things about your show
some big deal people came out in support
of your show yes some really some some
high-end folks proved to be fans and it
was very helpful to getting the show
picked up again that's really nice you
know we had lin-manuel Miranda you
treated what are you
yeah renew Brooklyn nine-nine I only
watch like poor things this is one yeah
I believe we had a Mark Hamill tweeted
about the show yeah yeah so now ready to
say bye-bye 99 wolf the dali lama's we
did didn't we yeah there it is
[Laughter]
I think we got tweeted about by mana
fort Oh manifold yeah
boom dad
yeah and then and I think blue blue the
Velociraptor tweeted about it
spots crease cats hashtag Andre Braugher
is daddy yeah anyway I don't know you
have a lot of fans in high place yeah
and broward be sad II don't know what
you're talking about that's cool
you